there were not many moments in the 2020
presidential campaign when Joe Biden
appeared in public and answered
questions on the fly without any notes
to guide him uh to the extent Biden did
sit for interviews he only talked with
friendly Outlets that went out of their
way to help him answer their questions
but despite that assistance sometimes
things still went very wrong and one of
the more notable debacles came in
January of 2020 when Biden uh
participated in an election Forum at
Vice Biden was asked how he would change
the culture at ice or immigration a
custom enforcement his answer involved
the the usual angry yelling and finger
pointing but the substance of what Biden
said was so bizarre that it actually
left the vice interviewers speechless
let's watch that again what exact
changes would you bring to ice as an
agency I would hold ice agents
accountable if in fact they stepped over
my executive orders which is no arrest
of anyone outside of their school look
at the you know one of the things that's
happening is particularly for uh Latino
and Hispanic kids is the incredible
pressure on them in terms of their their
their their sense of security they go
off to school wondering whether when Mom
comes and Picks Them Up is she not going
to be there because a ice agent was
there to arrest her or they take she
takes them to the doctor that she's
going to not be there because she is
quote undocumented and nice agent is
going to pick them up so how do you
change the culture you change the
culture by saying you're going to get
fired you're fired if in fact you do
that you only arrest for the purpose of
dealing with a felony that's committed
and I don't count drunk driving as a
felony now even for vice that was a
little much Biden pledged to fire any
ice officer who arrested an illegal
immigrant for committing a federal
misdemeanor even though that is in the
job description of ice officers
enforcing the law is what they are
supposed to be doing and Biden just
publicly threatened to terminate anyone
who did the job that they signed up to
do and Joe Biden declared that drunk
driving is a misdemeanor even though in
many cases it's actually a felony so
it's it's an insane series of statements
for any presidential candidate to make
but it was an especially odd coming from
Biden who claimed for many years that
his wife and daughter were killed by a
drunk driver even though in typical
Biden fashion the story was a lie but um
completely unprompted in any event Biden
gave the green lights for illegal aliens
to drink and drive in the United States
without any fear of deportation or even
arrest so he he affirmed the right of
non-citizens to drive drunk in the
United
States now if you wanted to to terrorize
as many American citizens as possible
and ensure that thousands more people
die in drunk driving accidents every
year this is exactly the kind of policy
you would adopt you would provide
incentives for degenerate criminals
living in this country to commit even
more crimes by removing any fear in
their minds that they might get deported
if they disobey
four years ago it was easy to try and
dismiss Biden's remarks as a gaff or a
misstatement at the time that's exactly
what many on the left did but it was not
a misstatement at all it was instead a
deao part of the democratic party
platform that indeed illegal aliens
should be able to drive drunk as much as
they want without having to worry about
the consequences that is the platform
that Biden ran on let the illegals get
drunk and kill your family and fiery car
wrecks on the highway that was basically
the campaign motto it's what most of his
party's delegation in Congress believes
in and that is why yesterday 150
Democrats in the House of
Representatives voted no on a bill that
would allow for the automatic
deportation of illegal immigrants who
drink and drive whether it's a felony or
a misdemeanor the bill also would make
it harder for non-citizens convicted of
DUI to enter this country in the first
place again the overwhelming majority of
Democrats tried to block this bill so
they have no problem with foreign
Nationals entering into this country and
and then committing a dangerous crime
one that could easily get American
citizens killed unfortunately the bill
passed by uh 20 274 to 150 vote margin
with 59 Democrats joining the
Republicans but it was far closer than
it should have been and there should
have obviously not been a single person
voting against it of course the only
real issue with the bill if there is an
issue with it is that we should
automatically Deport all illegals anyway
sober or not but since that's not
happening this seems like a log IAL
place to start especially with all of
the many cases of illegals killing
Americans by driving drunk it happens
all the time that includes the case of
Jose menjar who uh just killed two
American citizens after racking up more
than a decade's worth of probation
violations and DUIs and that record
didn't stop Jose from getting in his
Toyota Tundra while drunk and doing it
all over again last month and here's how
that turned out watch D accused of
killing a mother and son near Broomfield
high school has a long history of
drinking and driving our Sean Boyd has
been digging into this case she is live
right now so Sean you have learned that
the suspect went before a judge in
Boulder just days before this
crash and Allan he plad guilty to drunk
driving on two separate occasions on top
of three prior drinking and driving
related convictions multiple probation
violations and failing to appear in
court repeatedly despite all that he
walked out of here on December 8th and 4
days later got behind the wheel while
drunk according to investigators and
killed a Broomfield mother and her son
court records show Jose menar Alice has
a history of drunk driving dating back
to 2007 he has four convictions in
Boulder County alone again and again
he's been put on probation and again and
again he's violated it continuing to
drink and drive until his next arrest in
each case he's been released on no or
low Bond failed to reappear for his
hearing and a warrant has been issued
for his arrest that may explain why he
didn't face sentencing for two DUI cases
from 2016 and 2019 until this month he
was allowed to plead both down to lesser
charges of driving while ability
impaired despite having three prior
drinking and driving related convictions
a Boulder County Judge sentenced him to
probation community service and work
release he left the courthouse and 4
days later investigators say he got
drunk got behind the wheel and drove his
truck into a car outside of Broomfield
High School killing Melissa Powell and
her 16-year-old
son what's not mentioned in that report
because local news stations don't like
to talk about IL illegal immigration is
that this man has a record of four
deportations he was kicked out of this
country in June 2009 June 2013 November
2014 and January 2015 but the border is
completely open so he just kept coming
back and after a while the federal
government just stopped deporting him
even though they had ample opportunity
to do so he was arrested multiple times
in this country after his last
deportation in particular for DUIs on
December 7th 2016 and May 7th 2019 none
of that mattered to the doj or to the
leftwing judges in Colorado so here we
are prosecutors wanted to send him to
prison for a year but the judge whose
name is Zack ainson again released him
and now as a direct result of that
decision and all the decisions before it
two people are dead as a result and
here's the kicker all he has to do is
come up with $10,000 out of his $100,000
bond and he can get out and he get drunk
and kill some more American citizens
this is the kind of degeneracy that
Democrats want in this country they just
voted to make it harder to deport
illegal aliens just like this killer and
there are lot of killers like him in
2021 there was the case of Ernesto Lopez
Morales a Guatemalan who was illegally
living in Florida Ernesto was driving a
Suburban with no lights on when he
plowed into another vehicle pushing it
600 feet off the road and killing a
5-year-old girl inside and then he fled
the
scene now what happened to arnesto he
was charged with manslaughter given a
$22,500
bond which he could post within just a
couple with just a couple thousand
dollar he was not immediately removed
from this country or even forced to stay
behind bars after killing a 5-year-old
then there was the case of the illegal
alien who killed NFL linebacker Edwin
Jackson and also his rid share driver
around 400 a.m on a Sunday morning
Jackson became sick so the driver pulled
over to the shoulder of the interstate
in Indianapolis uh both men got out of
the car and that's when another
intoxicated Guatemala National named
Manuel Oro Savala drove his Ford F-150
into the emergency Lan Lane and killed
Jackson and his
driver now this incident never should
have happened happened because Manuel
shouldn't have been in the United States
in the first place Manuel had a previous
DUI conviction and two deportations one
in 2007 another in 2009 in other words
he's exactly the kind of person that
those 150 Democrats want to keep in this
country there are many more examples
along these lines there's the case of
alfio Augustine who had two convictions
for driving Under the Influence one in
September 2019 another in January 2020
he got deported because of the latter
arrest but of course had no problem
getting back into the country where on
one Sunday night late last year he got
drunk and nearly killed a man with his
Chevy Malibu then there's the reported
illegal alien Juan Felix uh Avendano who
recorded who according to Wisconsin now
was driving 106 miles per hour in a 40 m
mile per hour Zone when he slammed into
the back of a vehicle carrying Jan and
George shiming 76 and 78 years old and
their son Craig shiming 52 while the
family was on the way to church and
shiming later died just weeks earlier
also Wisconsin an illegal alien named
Ernest um Ernest Regalado killed a
20-year-old nurse in a DUI wreck and you
know we could go on all day through the
list of illegal aliens who have killed
American citizens and their prior rap
sheets suffice it to say the fact that
we're not enforcing immigration law even
against DUI offenders is clearly getting
people killed these are incidents that
should fill us with absolute rage and
disgust now of course it's an outrage
and a tragedy anytime somebody is killed
by a drunk driver but the idea that
we're allowing the dregs of humanity
from other countries to come here
illegally and kill good productive
law-abiding citizens of our community
it's just unconscionable if your house
is feeling chilly right now you may need
to consider window replacements I get it
for most homeowners window replacement
isn't something they've ever done before
and it may seem like a bit of a daunting
task luckily there's a company that will
do the work for you Renewal by and
Anders is your One-Stop shop for window
design manufacturer and installation
Windows play a crucial role in
regulating indoor temperatures if you
notice a spike in your heating or
cooling bills it may be due to
inefficient windows don't put it off any
longer Renewal by Anderson offers
limited fully transferable and best in
the nation warranty coverage right now
renewable by Anderson is offering a free
inhome consultation on quality energy
efficient Affordable Windows or patio
doors with special uh financing options
as well text Walsh to 200 300 for a free
consultation to save $375 off every
window and
$775 off every door these savings won't
last long so be sure to check it out by
texting Walsh to2 20030 that's Walsh to2
200 300 texting privacy policy terms and
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages message data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer details so what then is the
argument against this bill what's the
argument against deporting illegal
aliens who have been convicted of
DUIs here's representative permilla jaia
paal to try to explain what that
argument is let's listen once again the
majority is wasting our time by putting
forward a piece of legislation that has
zero chance of becoming law and that is
extraordinarily broad no one condones
driving Under the Influence we should do
everything we can to prevent people from
getting behind the wheel while
intoxicated but this bill designed to
scapegoat and denigrate immigrants will
not solve the serious problem of DUIs
Public Safety threats including those
who have been convicted of serious DUI
offenses are already inadmissible and
removable under the immigration and
nationality act and this bill would not
change or enhance that under the Ina a
conviction of a crime involving moral
turpitude where the punishment can be
for a year or longer makes an individual
deportable courts have ruled over and
over again that serious DUI offenses
that put others at risk are cimts and
make the perpetrators deportable but
this bill isn't about serious offenses
Mr Speaker far from it the bill says
that a conviction for a single DUI
offense misdemeanor or felony makes you
instantly deportable and an admission to
such an offense makes you instantly
inadmissible no questions asked I can
understand maybe the appeal of something
that sounds like a zero tolerance policy
but let me tell you Mr Speaker if we had
that kind of policy here in the House of
Representatives there would be several
members that would not be members of
this chamber so that last part there is
a complete non sequitor of course
whether lawmakers have driven drunk is
irrelevant because we're talking about a
bill that applies to illegal aliens
people who have already violated the law
and who who have no legal right to be in
this country and then and then commit
another crime on top of that so it's not
clear why she's suggesting that some
members of Congress would be affected by
this legislation in any way unless she's
admitting something about the
immigration status of one of her
colleagues which isn't that hard to
imagine actually and I will say that if
there are any illegal alien congressmen
uh or women I absolutely IM infavor of
deporting them
immediately and you know no need to wait
for them to drive drunk so so that
should solve that in fact actually I'm
in favor of deporting 95% of Congress
even if they're citizens so we could
talk about that that's a separate piece
of legislation we could work on but the
Crux of jaia Paul's argument is that she
doesn't condone DUI and uh she thinks
that uh she that we should do everything
we can to prevent people from driving
while intoxicated but at the same time
she opposes the bill because it's Broad
and it quote scapegoats and denigrates
immigrants specifically ja Paul
complains that this bill doesn't Focus
only on serious offenses and instead
would make an immigrant instantly
deportable for any DUI offense at all
now reasonable people see that part of
this bill as a feature not a bug the
only difference between a serious DUI
and one that jaia Paul and apparently
Biden don't deem serious is that nobody
was hurt or killed by the non-serious
one but but that's only a matter of luck
Okay the reason why it's bad to get
behind the wheel when you're drunk is
that you could kill someone or yourself
or multiple people even if in most cases
it doesn't end that way everybody who
commits a DUI is putting lives at risk
whether they actually kill somebody or
not and an illegal immigrant should be
given zero latitude to put American
lives at risk at all under any
circumstance and to any
degree so these are not exactly strong
arguments so far but she keeps going so
let's keep
listening moreover by including every
single type of DUI offense this bill
will would make someone deportable for
not driving Under the Influence that's
because states have a wide variety of
opinions on what is a DUI for example
Arizona's DUI statute allows people to
be charged with the DUI if they are
intoxicated and have quote physical
control of their vehicle the night
circuit found that the breath of this
statute means that and I'm quoting here
one may be convicted under it for
sitting in one's own car in one's own
driveway with the key in the ignition
and a bottle of beer in one's hand end
quote because of this the ninth circuit
determined that a conviction under this
statute was insufficient to count as a
deportable offense as the court put it
drunken driving is Despicable having
physical control of a car while drinking
is not their words not mine as many
places across the country experienced
coal spells in the last week or so there
are states that would allow prosecution
of someone simply if they were sitting
in their car with the heat on while
inebriated even if it was in their own
driveway nothing about that made any I'm
starting to think that maybe she herself
was drunk while delivering that speech
so maybe she's a little bit biased uh
even her she emphasizes the law she says
you would go to jail for sitting in your
own car well how is yeah like as opposed
to sitting in someone yes yes if you're
sitting in your own car and you're drunk
then then that's a DUI is that supposed
to be
shocking so here she spends a long time
complaining that some states consider it
a DUI if you're sitting in a parked car
in your own car your own car with a key
in the ignition drinking alcohol but not
driving and jaul apparently considers it
absurd to criminalize that kind of
behavior because the most liberal appell
Court in the country says so she also
seems to think that the cold temperature
might necessitate somebody sitting in
the car while they drink a beer I'm not
sure I follow that logic how does that
excuse work well sorry officer I'm just
sitting here chugging this beer in my
car with the key and the ignition
because
um it's cold outside so it's an
interesting argument because as we saw
gaop Paul herself just said that we
should do everything we can to prevent
people from driving drunk but apparently
doing everything can to prevent people
from driving drunk does not include
arresting them before they start driving
so we got to wait for the intoxicated
person to actually start driving the
4,000 pound hunk of metal down the road
and through a neighborhood before we
arrest them according to this logic but
it seems to me that there there couldn't
possibly be any valid reason for a
person to sit in the driver's seat with
the key of the ignition while
inebriated like it's it's a very safe
assumption that their intention is to
drive and we often arrest people for
attempting to do things even if they
have not done the thing yet take
attempted murder for example if you take
overt steps towards killing someone but
you don't you still go to prison for a
very long time and by the same token if
you if you take overt steps towards
drunk driving like getting drunk and
then getting in a car and putting a key
in the inition then you should go to
prison and if you're an illegal alien
you should be
deported but really this is a Mot point
because there's a very simple answer to
the question of how much leeway should
we give illegal immigrants who are
already committing a crime just by being
in this country in the first place the
answer is they deserve no leeway and no
leniency whatsoever whether they're
driving drunk or not they should all be
deported if they're in this country and
they should be barred from entering if
they're not right now though a lot of
Republicans seem to disagree with that
they're close to agreeing to a border
deal with the Biden Administration that
would still permit thousands of illegals
to enter this country every day uh and
here's their reasoning behind that
the height of stupidity is having a
strong opinion on something you know
nothing about I'm I'm extremely
disappointed in the very strange
maneuvering by many on the right to to
to
torpedo uh a potential border Reform
Bill if we have a bill that on net
significantly decreases illegal
immigration and we sabotage that that is
that is inconsistent with what we told
our voters we would do people will make
up whatever reasons they they want to
there's a number of them I'm sure but it
would be pretty unacceptable dereliction
of of your
duty now this compromised Position will
still allow 5,000 illegal immigrants to
enter this country every day that's
nearly 2 million illegals every single
year it's not a compromise it will just
encourage more illegal immigrants to
come here in the hopes that they'll be
allowed in it's not going to reduce
illegal migration whatsoever but even if
it did a reduction isn't enough uh is is
not enough a simple reduction we now
have illegal Ians who are so emboldened
that they're attacking police officers
and then immediately getting out of jail
while flipping the bird to the camera
just happened in New York the other day
as you might have seen anyone telling
you to try to compromise on this uh
doesn't want you to realize that we've
been trying to compromise for several
decades now and with every American
citizen who's killed by an illegal
migrant or beaten in Time Square it
becomes abundantly clear that the time
for compromise is long over
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast